tony busby is one of the lawyers
representing lieutenant colonel stuart
cheller he joins us tonight mr busby
thanks so much for defending this man
and for coming on the show tonight so if
we misstated anything is he in jail
right now
he's sitting in jail right now
with no formal charges against him
uh supposedly there's supposed to be a
hearing
on thursday but he doesn't even know
what he's charged with
and
you know of course he still remains
under this illegal gag order so this
story broke i think last night
in that time how many members of
congress have reached out to you to say
we will no longer approve a single
promotion in the u.s military until this
this prisoner of conscience is freed
a lot none
no none and i'll tell you what's what's
more more what's more infuriating
is that today we had testimony in the
senate
where uh they tried to make the case
that uh the withdrawal was an
operational success
uh it's not a success of course to the
13 families who lost loved ones uh and
when somebody tried to speak out and say
look we could have done a lot better we
owed these marines and sailors and army
personnel better than that
they not only told him to shut up
when he didn't shut up they put him in
jail
he's a married man with children
he's married man yes with children and
and i would say his spirits are high uh
the the support not not of course
congressional support but the support
that we have received that he has
received that his family has received
has been overwhelming people see this
for what it is they see this from the
top the top brass trying to shirk
responsibility and when somebody in the
chain of command speaks up they're
silenced and we can do better than that
this is a man
who is a 17-year marine a marine officer
an infantry officer just like i was a
guy who who's conscious uh required him
to speak out and and the american
military and specifically the united
states marine corps the the entity that
i love so much has has put him in jail
for that and people are are just coming
together all over the united states that
the pipe hitter uh organization the
foundation has raised already 200 000
for his defense this is wrong and will
not stand
you think of all those members of
congress who you know serve six months
in the jag corps somewhere and brag
about their military service and how you
know they're for the troops and here are
24 extra billion dollars saying that one
word about this honorable man who is the
best of america rotting in jail with
criminals tonight first telling the
truth
it's beyond belief it's disgusting and i
appreciate tony busby your defense of
him and i hope you'll come back
thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else